i think you're right this is a kind of
eye-opening moment where
basically what we've seen for the last
year or so is this kind of a narco
tyranny
where you're right conservatives are
right to say that there's this effort to
kind of defang the police or at least
get them to back off of policing a
certain kind of crime in a certain kind
of criminal
but that doesn't mean that they're
actually de-policing they're just
focusing more on enforcing things like
mass mandates or like you said
arresting proud boys and people like
that a good example is this guy
jonathan petlin there's a drill
instructor
at a base in the south the
the specific state of losing right now
but basically this guy
got into a confrontation with a suspect
who happened to be black
uh this guy was like a repeat offender
in the neighborhood what you don't
what you didn't hear from from the
stories that broke was that this guy had
repeatedly come into this neighborhood
and harassed people and specifically had
grabbed uh
young women made them feel very
uncomfortable there's
a claim that he's like mentally unstable
whatever okay but
but here's the part that the story that
the news really didn't focus on was that
the police had actually
known about this guy and they let him
out like they knew that he was walking
about
but they the argument was we didn't want
to make him a statistic
so when people would report him to us we
would kind of slap him on the wrist and
then let him go and he would go back
into this community and harass people
so one day uh a woman goes and gets this
guy jonathan patlin and says he's back
you know do something about it and he
goes and confronts the guy and you i
don't know if you saw the video
okay it goes viral he says you're in the
wrong neighborhood uh he's really
confrontational for right reason because
there's
things that happened leading up to that
the police absolutely destroyed jonathan
palin's life they crucified him
within 48 hours there were people at his
house throwing things through the window
the military completely disavowed him
his own unit
framed him as a white extremist a white
supremacist like the guy's reputation
is ruined he in the in the thing and he
was just like like
trying to be a middle-aged guy who saw
someone harassing women and doing the
job that cops wouldn't do because they
were because the cops were more
concerned with avoiding
the stigma of being called racist and
doing their jobs this is the
perfect example of why i have been
saying abolish the police
and it is somewhat tongue-in-cheek but
not completely
the point i'm trying to make is if we
are really moving into this era
where the police know we can't go after
anybody who might be defended by the
left because we don't want to deal with
it and we'll lose our budgets but we can
arrest
anybody on the right all day and night
and get praised for it
then what do you think is going to
happen in this instance the cops
they knew they knew who this guy was
they don't
care about this guy john petlan's life
who seemed to be according to this story
a regular guy who was like these these
young women in my neighborhood are being
harassed by this guy i'm going to make
it stop
i mean i watch that video and i'm like
what did the guy really do he like got
got up to him said back off back off get
out of here and pushed him
shouldn't have shoved him push pushed
him when he was walking towards his wife
which is actually the thing that the
police
the sheriff uh the i don't know the
sheriff chief whatever
said that's that's like the evidence
right there for for ruining this guy's
life
is the fact that he he shoved him but of
course what you see in that video is
that the guy starts approaching his wife
he's he's like he's his wife says
something to him and the guy starts
walking towards him and steps on his
property and that's when he shoves him
and says that's my wife
and that's when the cops were like
that's that's where he crossed the line
when he shoved the guy
like the cop ruined a guy's life because
he pushed somebody yes
because the left claimed he was racist
for for shoving
a young black man saying you're in the
wrong neighborhood so it's like social
pressure that ruined this they used
social pressure to try to ruin this
activist politics they didn't do social
pressure pushing because
because initially initially he got uh it
was basically the equivalent of like a
citation because he slapped the guy's
phone out of his hand right
okay but then pressure is mounting
you know there's this outrage in the
community about this racist white man
who's telling like a young black man
he's in the wrong neighborhood
and so so the police went back and said
oh we have new evidence that shows that
you know
he shoved him it's like that's not new
that was the video that went viral uh
and that justifies
ultimately the penalty was like it was
like a short like a few days in jail and
like a a
5 000 fight or something it was really
small but that's
that's nothing compared to the damage to
this guy's reputation
like the the hoa where he lives like
disavowed him in a statement
saying that like you know racism has no
home in this community
like i said the hoa the police the
military the media
as far as these organs these entities
that i just named are concerned like
this guy is a vile racist
who does not belong in polite society
his life is ruined this is like
they they say often that history doesn't
repeat but it rhymes
you know that that phrase but this is
just such a great example of
banishment and how banishment has kind
of come back around now and now we have
this social banishment ostracization
conservatives need to call the bluff of
the left they need to call the bluff and
say
we hereby believe all cops should be
abolished and there's two reasons for it
you see what they'll do to this guy you
see what happens anarcho-tyranny
they will not enforce the laws to
protect you but they will enforce the
law against you and the second reason is
y'all are gun owners why are you worried
about petty crime in your neighborhood
and what the police are going to do
about it
if the left wants to abolish cops if
cops are then willing to ruin a man's
life not every single cop i know
call their bluff because how fast do you
think we saw this in minneapolis
when when they were like we want to
abolish the police and then the city
council is like we hereby vote to
abolish the police no wait stop
don't do it the city council members
panicked and freaked out
so i'll put it this way i've had
leftists tweet like
tim poole only wants to abolish the
police because he knows that
when the when the police are gone the
leftists will get really angry or he
thinks they will and i'm like
well that's partly correct right i am
100 confident
if the police actually got abolished you
will see
every regular american wake up
and that's one of the biggest problems
frogs boiling in a pot conservatives can
sit here all day and night and say
if we don't stop the the the tide from
the
the flood waters from rising if we don't
put up sandbags
we will drown and people are sitting
there just like i don't care
it's not flooding in my house right and
then within a month they're on the
second floor being like i don't i don't
care like i'm safe here on the second
floor
okay call them on their bluff say okay
look
i'll put it this way the other the other
point the other side of this is that may
be part
partially true that i definitely think
the moment you actually try to abolish
the police
regular people will come out screaming
begging you to stop
but the other issue is exactly what
we've been talking about
it's only a matter of time before we see
more police arrest regular people
we saw with the mccloskeys people
actually go on to their private property
go on to their lawns the mccloskeys come
out
okay they shouldn't have been
brandishing the guns the way they were i
was very
ill advised in that capacity but should
they have been arrested had their guns
seized from them and the cops
will do it with no questions asked then
you have in wisconsin
this group of black lives matter
activists who had previously set fire to
a home on
twice in one day they started a house on
fire i guess they came put the fire out
in the neck and then
after they leave they went and set fire
to it again then you get this guy he's
sitting in his house and he sees this
group
he's got a shotgun and he and he
brandishes it up
through his like at his window he's
windows closed the police show up
knock on his door and arrest him and i'm
like so here you go
let let it be known okay if you think
you will be spared by the police you're
insane
you are insane we have seen on numerous
occasions with
that's three examples right now that if
black lives matter comes to your home
and i said this before this guy got
arrested i said it's only a matter of
time
before black lives matter will show up
to your house
and the cops will look around and say it
is easier to arrest the homeowner than
to deal with a riot
and they will arrest you who did nothing
wrong in your own home
now we're seeing examples of this it was
never going to be overnight
it was going to be slowly and gradually
and it's going to get worse and if
people just keep sitting back saying
the cops are on my side you're wrong 100
wrong
it's interesting because antifa or let's
call them black blocks these thugs right
they think of themselves as these kind
of revolutionary revolutionaries
but in many ways they're basically just
state sanctioned thugs
and in that sense i think of lumpin
proletariat
which was this this term that marx used
to describe
uh people without any real sense of
class consciousness
they're basically just the term he uses
social scum
uh as opposed to actual proletariat and
they ultimately because they're social
scum and they really just want to break
things and they can't they're incapable
of building anything and they're
just a bunch of criminals and
degenerates which is true i mean
i'm talking about it for antifa right
okay
so ultimately what they end up being is
tools of reactionary intrigue
and what he means by that is these these
are people who think that they're
involved in something important but
they're not
they're just being used by the state as
as kind of like
you know like i said state-sanctioned
thugs or i mean
uh on the other hand uh what antifa does
antifa window repair this is great
for the biggest most powerful
corporations in this country
it's great for amazon when the small
brick and mortar business gets burned to
the ground by antifa
it's great for walmart when the small
shop gets
destroyed and incinerated during riots
this is great jeff bezos
at the same time that these riots were
happening last year and
people were having their livelihoods
eradicated jeff bezos made
or increased his his uh his worth by 13
billion in a single day
and the reason for that is partly due to
the fact that
you could still buy from amazon right
but you couldn't go to the local mom and
pop shop
big box stores were given special
exemptions we saw this in michigan
where like a local i can't remember what
it was i think it was like a flower
flowers and like plant shop was like
shut down but then the gardening area of
walmart is left open
so they say whoa but walmart sells food
and a lot of people said okay should i
sell
loaves of bread at my hobby shop so i
can stay open
well that's that that's the game that
was being played
the massive transfer of wealth but it
wasn't just
democrat cities saying we're going to
destroy small businesses
at the same time you had mass unrest
thousands of people marching to the
street shoulder to shoulder and what did
the media say
what did the universities say what did
the democrat politician say
this is not spreading covet your
business is shut down
because a little old grandma walking in
to buy milk could cause the apocalypse
but 2 000 people shoulder to shoulder
marching through new york
gets a round of applause from the
doctors we see those stupid
propaganda photos where the nurses like
standing in front of the car and the
woman in the car is saying like you know
honk for freedom or something
and then all the people on the internet
are like look at these brave nurses
fighting for us stopping these stupid
anti-lockdown protesters
then a video comes out people marching
through new york
thousands and nurses and doctors walk
outside and start clapping for them
and when questioned they said but racism
is the real public health crisis
yeah it's another i mean this is another
example of going back to this discussion
about the fbi and the capitol police
using these
these fabricated threats or these
exaggerated threats to
to justify their budgets and their
operations the cdc declared
recently racism as a public health
threat and they tied it to the need for
more funding right
i love it when the cops all took a knee
at these protests cops fbi
national guard and and the and basically
pledging fealty to the extremists
and now we're seeing the implementation
of what that ideology really means and
mark milley
joint chiefs of staff saying like you
know getting full woke but i want to
understand this stuff he says
and then you still have conservatives
i'm watching i came i was watching i was
watching a live stream
and people are yelling back to blue and
i'm like man
pay attention dude those people that
you're defending
took a knee for black lives matter yep
all right support them i guess thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you